hat ja einen absoluten Punkt wenn er
sagt es wird in Deutschland unfassbar
viel weggeklagt sie sagen sieben Leute
reichen wenn die sich zusammentun dann
macht auch Herr Huber und auch wieder
machen die gar nichts mehr ist das so es
ist ist es im Grunde egal wo jemand
sitzt also ich habe neulich die schöne
Geschichte des Vaters von Karl Theodor
zu Guttenberg auch ein CSU Mann gelesen
er noch zu Gutenberg der diesen kleinen
Verein hatte der was gemacht hat
vehement gegen Windkraft zu Felde zieht
und der natürlich damit auch viel
verhindert wir können generell sagen
dass bei uns natürlich auch ganz viel
geklagt wird gegen Windkraft
aber wir setzen uns damit auseinander
und wir gehen an die Öffentlichkeit und
wir akzeptieren das nicht sondern wir
setzen den NABU unter Druck und
bringen anderes Bild in die
Öffentlichkeit und wir haben natürlich
die gleichen Rahmenbedingungen wie sie
in Bayern aber wir haben in NRW in
diesem Jahr schon 82 Genehmigung
bekommen im ersten Quartal wir als Firma
allein 20 und
Niedersachsen 22 Schleswig-Holstein 33
Sachsen-Anhalt 2020 also Unterschied ist
einfach der wie redet man über die
erneuerbaren Energien wenn man sagt
möglichst weit weg möglichst aha
eigentlich wollen wir sie gar nicht dann
wirkt sich das auch bis in die
Genehmigungsbehörden aus wenn es aber
umgekehrt ist und man sagt wir wollen
sie haben diese Energieform da wirkt das
auch in die Genehmigungsbehörden hinein
und wir haben bei uns trotz höchster
Dichte in NRW eine hohe Akzeptanz das
liegt auch daran dass wir die Bürger
mitnehmen wir beteiligen sie wir geben
Ihnen günstige Stromtarife das sind ganz
wichtige Maßnahme die Kilowattstunde
bitte das Verlangen sie für die
Kilowattstunde wir haben Preise auf
jeden Fall unter 40 Cent in allen
Bereichen und wir gehen runter bis unter
20 Cent je nachdem was genau im Internet
bei ihm zahlt man 30 Cent für die
Kilowattstunde das ist jetzt ganz normal
also
vom bundesdurchschnittlich deutlich
höher das sind ja auch noch nicht mal
die besonders geförderte Tarif
differenzieren das je nachdem wo die
Menschen wohnen und was die
Windkraftbetreiber bereit sind zu
sponsern eine ganz wichtige Maßnahme und
dann kommt jetzt dazu das gibt nämlich
im Moment die Industrie will den Strom
haben wir haben jeden Tag Anfragen aus
der Industrie die sagen könnt ihr uns
helfen und das verändert sehr sehr viel
wir haben jetzt mehrere Gemeinden da
haben sich alle Gewerbebetriebe
zusammengeschlossen
und Schreiben gemeinsam an ihrem
Bürgermeister wir brauchen in der Summe
so viel Strom bitte Stellflächen zur
Verfügung für ausreichend Wind und Solar
damit wir uns komplett grün versorgen
können und da brauchen wir dann gar
nicht mehr über Verpflichtungen und
Flächen Bereitstellung diskutieren wenn
die Gewerbebetriebe sich so aufstellen
und das passiert jetzt gerade dann ist
das Thema durch genau das machen wir
doch auch ich habe gerade angesprochen
das Beispiel aus meiner Heimat vor 30
bis 40 Wind Energieanlagen installiert
werden sollen auch für die chemische
Industrie genau das läuft ja auch bei
uns genau auf dem Weg sind wir doch auch
aber
erneuerbare Energien nicht
ausschließlich Wind sind es mag ja sein
dass sie das Vorhaben bis jetzt läuft es
nicht so aber noch kein einziger Fehler
bei den Erneuerbaren ausschließlich auf
den Wind nicht Biomasse es geht um
Photovoltaik es geht darum Wasserkraft
es geht darum Termin die ganze
Wärmebereich ist natürlich auch in
Bayern gut abgeben haben
ist eine eine Stärke Bar und wo wir auch
natürlich sowohl in der Stromerzeugung
als auch in der Wärmeversorgung gut
ausgestattet sind wir haben ja auch das
Ziel dass wir 25% der Gebäude Wärme in
den nächsten Jahren durch geotopie
nutzen wollen also eine bayerische
Stärke ich habe keine Rolle auf der
Bundesliga
reden
wir sagen für ein ausgeglichenen Mix wo
wir möglichst wenig Lücken hinterlassen
bei der Erzeugung brauchen wir solar
wind und Bioenergie die Bio-Energie wird
oft kaputt geredet von den
Umweltverbänden das finde ich auch
völlig falsch die Bioenergie hatten ganz
hohen Stellenwert sehen worüber reden
wir dann konkret ja sogar über Holz über
ähm
was man alles nutzen kann das müssen wir
auch nutzen und in dieser Kombination
können wir eine ziemlich gesicherte
Stromversorgung machen dass wir nicht
dafür brauchen weil es viel zu teuer ist
ist der Wasserstoff was sie ganz in den
Vordergrund stellen sie haben in Bayern
paar sehr gute Voraussetzungen gehabt
nämlich die Wasserkraft wegen der
Alpenflüsse und das Molassebecken in
München wo man gut Geothermie machen
kann das ist auch okay die ist dass sie
das nutzen aber das sind begrenzte
Ressourcen darauf können sie sich nicht
lange ausruhen die Wasserkraft geht
nämlich zurück wegen der Trockenheit
schon in den letzten Jahren aufgrund von
Klimawandel deutlich zurückgegangen so
und das heißt sie werden in Zukunft
einen Mix machen müssen aus diesen
wichtigen drei Ressourcen und da wird
die Windenergie in massiv auf die Füße
fallen wenn Sie die nicht
ausbauenfähigkeit immer noch nicht
beantwortet doch ich habe es ja gerade
gesagt
nicht funktioniert vor allem wir müssen
eine sehen wenn wir über Transformation
reden über Energiewende reden was heißt
es was heißt das konkret das heißt dass
wir sämtliche fossilen
Produktionsprozesse umstellen auf Strom
umstellen auf Elektrifizierung
das heißt der Strombedarf in Deutschland
insgesamt wird sich vervielfachen und
deswegen müssen wir uns verdoppeln
mindestens mindestens also wenn ich mir
so manche Branchen anschaue also
beispielsweise ein Einstieg in die
Wasserstoffwirtschaft und der chemischen
Industrie würde bedeuten das allein die
chemische Industrie so viel Strom
braucht wie jetzt ganz Deutschland
insgesamt so und das schaffen sie
natürlich
sie müssen auch für die
grundlassfähigkeit Sorgen und es hilft
mir ja nichts wenn ich finanziell am
Sonntagnachmittag bei strahlendem
Sonnenschein und sind an der Küste mehr
Strom produziert als ich brauche nicht
am Montag Vormittag um 10 Uhr nicht habe
deswegen brauchen wir auch zur Sicherung
des Wirtschaftsstandort die
grundlastfähigkeit und die werde ich nur
mit der Kombination aus Erneuerbaren
nicht hinbringen geschweige denn
geschweige denn dass ich ja die Fläche
gar nicht habe sie müssen sich nur mal
überlegen sie müssen sich doch nur mal
überlegen wie viel Fotovoltaik brauchen
Sie um alles selbst erzeugen zu können
was sie brauchen das wird gar nicht
funktionieren deswegen brauchen wir
natürlich schon auch eine Wasserstoff
Infrastruktur deswegen monieren wir ja
auch aus Bayern heraus so sehr dass die
Ampel beim Wasserstoff nicht Bayern
vernachlässigt dass wir fünf oder zehn
Jahre später dran kommen sollen deswegen
haben wir auch eigene Initiativen wo man
natürlich auch schauen dass wir aus dem
Süden heraus eine wasserstoffpipeline
nach Bayern waren weil wir natürlich
Wasserstoff schon brauchen als als
Grundprodukte keine Heimat Energie mehr
wenn Sie den Wasserstoff machen in jedem
Fall die Möglichkeit von der Illusion
verabschieden dass ein Industriestandort
wie Deutschland dich komplett erneuerbar
versorgen kann aber das ist doch immer
noch kein gegenangement dagegen jetzt
die Erneuerbaren wirklich auszubauen
oder die Windkraft auch mit
einzuschließen und die Herausforderung
wäre doch auch so viel über erneuerbare
mit Wind und Solar zu produzieren dass
unser grundlastbedarf sehr sehr gering
ist und eben nur noch in speziellen
momentan wir den nutzen müssen und dann
zum Beispiel auch auf eine sehr kostbare
sehr sehr teure Technologie wie
Wasserstoff zurückgreifen können in
diesen Momenten aber ansonsten natürlich
muss das Ziel doch sein dass wir die
Technologien die so günstig sind wo
schon komplett klar ist wie das
funktioniert dass wir die jetzt erstmal
nutzen und das sind geben die
Solarenergie aber eben auch die
Windkraft und wenn sie dann von
fehlenden Flächen sprechen dann frage
ich mich ehrlicherweise das ist doch
eine Frage des Landes wie viele Fläche
man überhaupt ausweicht
sie wollen natürlich sämtliche
Produktionsprozesse sämtliche
Anwendungen auch umstellen von den
fossilen Energieträgern auf synthetische
Kraftstoffe auf auf strombasierte dann
müssen sie sich immer mehr überlegen was
heißt das denn an Flächenbedarf der
Flughafen München beispielsweise ja
könnte natürlich auch mit versorgt
werden wissen Sie wie viel Fläche sie
brauchen mit Photovoltaik um den halben
Bedarf da muss man noch mal realistisch
sein sie bräuchten mehrere hundert
Quadratkilometer
um den Strom zu erzeugen damit sie damit
sie dann die Fluss herstellen um den
halben Bedarf des Flughafen Münchens zu
haben also da muss man doch mal sehen
wenn sie dann überlegen dass wir jetzt
mindestens eine verdoppeln eine
Verdreifachung des Strombedarf in
Deutschland haben
eine märchenlösung sind die Probleme
wirklich lösen können und ich habe das
Gefühl dass es die
dumm die Taktik die die CSU und die CDU
gerade am allermeisten fahren wir haben
bewährte Technologien von denen wir
wissen dass sie funktionieren wo wir sie
wo wir sie jetzt flächendeckend
ausrollen müssen und zwar
Stichwort und jedes Mal wenn wir das
haben kommen sie um die Ecke werfen eine
zweite halbgaretechnologien in den Raum
die sehr viel mehr Energie verbraucht
die wir nicht flächendecken nutzen
können die sehr teuer sein wird und
wollen da mit diesem Argument den Ausbau
von den Technologien verhindern bei
denen wir schon wissen dass sie zu hören
verteidigen müssen was hier über die
Jahre nicht mit verbockt haben
sie hat entscheiden Innenministerien für
eine
Klimawende die nötig war und die erkannt
worden war besetzt sie hatten sehr lange
das Landwirtschaftsministerium und sehr
lange das Verkehrsministerium was haben
Sie damals gemacht sie haben das Verbot
von Glyphosat gestoppt gegen die gegen
die Linie der Bundesregierung sie haben
sich an einer Pkw-Maut verkämpft wo klar
war das wird der Europäische Gerichtshof
oder wo sehr schnell klar war das wird
der Europäische Gerichtshof nicht
mitmachen sie haben in vielen Bereichen
im Verkehr alles nach Bayern geschoben
das hat Herr Söder im Land im
Bundestagswahlkampf explizit gelobt dass
der damalige Verkehrsminister andreas
Scheuer Millionenbeträge nach Bayern
gewartet insofern heimische nicht nur
Energie sondern heimische Vorteile
leisten andere Bundesländer und jetzt
haben sie ein bayerischen Scherbenhaufen
was ihre Umweltpolitik betrifft und Herr
Söder hat eine Zeit lang die Bäume
umarmt jetzt fangen sie an die Windräder
zu den Namen die ihn aber fehlen so
viele können sie gar nicht umarmen und
was sie jetzt sagen ich das ist ihr Job
dafür sind sie Generalsekretär das
müssen sie machen aber es wird nicht
dadurch besser indem sie alles in die
Zukunft richten und sagen was sie machen
wollen und was alles ganz toll ist in
Bayern sondern die CSU ist mit dafür
verantwortlich wo wir heute stehen und
zwar nicht gut und dann wäre es
vielleicht gut daraus auch Konsequenzen
zu ziehen und ein bisschen
selbstkritisch noch darauf hinweisen
dass wir auch beim Zubau der
erneuerbaren Energien auf Nummer eins
sind also das was sie sagen wir würden
irgendwas blockieren das stimmt halt
einfach nicht
zugeben aus keinem Bundesland wird so
viel Strom also erneuerbaren Energien
erzeugt wie in Bayern ist es ein
Argumente also zwei Sachen das erste
dass ich nur kurz abhauen wollte schon
die ganze Zeit und jetzt komme ich
endlich dazu es ist wirklich so wenn
sieben Leute einen Verein gründen und
Klagen gegen z.B Windräder egal die
könnten in Freiburg diesen Verein
gründen und die können gegen einen
Windkraftprojekt in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern klagen und wie
lange legen die das dann lahm sie
erleben sieben Leute können einen Verein
gründen und wenn die wenn das ein
umweltverein ist dann haben die nach
wenigen Monaten das Verbandsklagerecht
und können bundesweit
Infrastrukturprojekte kaputt klagen und
das kann so nicht weitergehen
und das
dauert in der Regel in der Vergangenheit
mehrere Jahre über mehrere Instanzen das
ist jetzt ein Vorteil dass ein Instanz
bei der Verwaltungsgerichtsbarkeit
weggefallen ist es dauert jetzt nicht
mehr mehrere Jahre sondern im Schnitt
vielleicht noch ein Jahr wer klagt da
wer was sind das für Leute das sind
einzelne Personen die sich als
Umweltschützer definieren und die aber
dann auch bewusst Leute aufnehmen und
ansprechen die gar nicht aus
Umweltgründen klagen sondern einfach
weil sie die Anlagen nicht sehen möchten
also das wird bewusst so gemacht
dass man sagt wenn ihr zu uns kommt
Mitglied werdet spendet dann klagen wir
für euch aus Umweltgründen gegen die
Veränderung
und das ist natürlich wirklich
Missbrauch des Klagerecht und hier muss
aufgeräumt werden was sind das für
Argumente die da vorgetragen werden so
die die ihre Top 2 wenn sie mal so
zurückdenken vorgetragen wird natürlich
immer der Artenschutz der Rotmilan zum
Beispiel der roten Milan den gibt es
überall aber ist angeblich selten und
wird angeblich gefährdet der ist aber im
Bestand überhaupt nicht gefährdet der
breitet sich wunderbar aus und da gibt's
keine echten Probleme aber er wird immer
hergenommen zu Verhinderung was noch
alle möglichen Vogelarten und felte
Hamster und so weiter also das ähm oder
dem Model Regenpfeifer der Modell
Regenpfeifer der Modell Regenpfeifer das
ist ein Steppen Vogel der vielleicht mal
durchzieht und dem wird nachgesagt dass
er Angst vor vertikalen Strukturen hat
sprich Windkraftanlagen also ein solcher
Unsinn
vorgetragen und damit muss man sich
auseinandersetzen aber ich sage auch das
Thema kennen wir wir sind aber trotzdem
erfolgreich auch wenn wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen und wir kommen auch da
weiter
eines muss klar sein wir haben in
Deutschland genügend Ressourcen und
Flächen um den gesamten Strom zu
erzeugen um den gesamten Strom zu
erzeugen für einen Elektrifizierung des
Verkehrs und um komplett die
Wärmeversorgung bereitzustellen das kann
man nachrechnen das kann man vorrechnen
genügend wie viel Prozent der Fläche wie
viel Prozent der Fläche würde das
bedeuten das sind ungefähr zwei Prozent
der Gesamtfläche das ist ja das ist ja
die Ausgangszahl gewesen Deutschland
komplett jawohl
mehr erneuerbarer Energie zu Wärme auch
als Wärme Wärme Mobilität alles alles
industrielle Prozesse nicht nicht
komplett noch Wasserstoff
aber den brauchen wir natürlich
Wasserstoff ausblenden beim
Industriestandort wie Deutschland wir
können doch nicht sagen wir können uns
versorgen und lassen den Wasserstoff für
die graust habe ich doch gar nicht
anders sagen
der Wasserstoff das Wort ich sage
Wasserstoff brauchen wir aber bitte nur
da wo es wirklich notwendig ist in der
Chemieindustrie in der Stahlindustrie
das wird sehr anstrengend und der ist
sehr teuer aber wo wir ihn brauchen
sollten wir noch nutzen und den können
wir auch importieren ich bin ja nicht
grundsätzlich dagegen etwas importieren
aber das was wir zu Hause machen können
was uns unabhängig macht dass der um was
kostengünstig ist das machen wir erstmal
zu Hause und dann bleibt noch einiges zu
importieren aber nichts grundsätzlich
dagegen Pauline Unger wenn wenn Sie das
so hören und
haben Sie das Gefühl die Politik nimmt
das wirklich ernst oder erleben wir auch
heute und es geht jetzt gar nicht gegen
Herrn Huber sonst erleben wir auch von
anderer Seite es geht am Ende sozusagen
geht es darum
Politik auch in gewisser Weise zu
verkaufen und den Leuten das Gefühl zu
geben wir tun die ganze Menge aber
eigentlich soll doch alles so
weitergehen wie gehabt ganz schön viel
also ich habe das ja eben schon
angesprochen ich habe das Gefühl was
wann von Seiten der CSU gerade hört
ehrlicherweise in vielen Punkten habe
ich das Gefühl dass es ein blanker
Populismus und der unzureichende Politik
noch irgendwie gut zu verkaufen und mich
erinnert das gerade aber an vielen
Stellen auch an die an die Politik in
Berlin die sie so viel kritisieren weil
ich das Gefühl habe dass das gerade
nennen muss da dass man sich in so
Märchengeschichten
verfängt und verliert und den Leuten
erzählt man könnte die Klimakrise
bekämpfen ohne dass das irgendeine
Veränderung bringt ohne dass es
Einschränkungen gibt ohne dass es
Verbote gibt oder ohne dass die Preise
steigen man räumt alle Möglichkeiten um
was verändern raus und sagt mit ein
bisschen Fäden Staub
kriegen wir das am Ende hin und das
schon darüber dass das auch zum Beispiel
eine Partei wie die grün Macht von denen
ich denken würde die stehen Ihnen
abiturell kulturell sehr nah ich glaube
die Situation in der Ampelkoalition muss
man sich vor allem so vorstellen dass
man da gerade zwei Parteien sitzen hat
und das sind die FDP und die SPD denen
das Klima offensichtlich egal ist also
wenn wir uns auch die politischen
Entscheidungen der letzten Woche
anschauen haben die nichts dafür getan
dass ich da irgendwas verbessert sondern
waren auch die treibenden Kräfte für
eine Verbesserung vom Klimaschutz und
vergleichsweise haben die Grünen sich
natürlich für den Klimaschutz eingesetzt
sind dann am Ende aber auch aus diesem
Koalitionsausschuss rausgegangen und tun
so als wäre gerade alles okay als hätten
komplet
dass man das da sozusagen an der Stelle
nicht so deutlich sagen kann aber ich
finde trotzdem dass man dass man das
betonen muss dass diese Koalition sich
gerade an vielen Stellen schon
hinstellen behauptet sie würde die
Klimakrise ernsthaft angehen und wenn
man sich das dann auf dem Papier
anschaut wenn man das durchrechnet dann
geht das nicht auf und dann geht das
wirklich bei weitem nicht auf
Christina und sehen sie auch so also das
was passiert da gerade wir haben nach
diesem Koalitionsausschuss zumindest
erlebt dass die Grünen sehr klar gesagt
haben so erreichen wir unsere Klimaziele
nicht deswegen ist ja auch der Eindruck
entstanden dass da eine sozialliberale
Koalition gerade gegen den eigenen
Partner grünen Gründe sie haben es ja
gerade damit auch angesprochen
Politik macht was diese Ampel für ein
Problem hat sie haben gesagt es würde so
getan das kostet alles nichts und wir
müssen nicht wirklich verzichten und ich
finde genau das umgekehrte ist passiert
mit diesem Aufschlag des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers bei dem
Heizungstausch ist vielen eben sehr klar
geworden das wird sehr teuer und das
wird sehr stark
Lösungen sagen das war der Reflex genau
weil weil darüber so deutlich geworden
ist
sehr Finger wurde in die Wunde gelegt es
ist klar es wird wahrscheinlich nur mit
ganz starken Vorgaben wahrscheinlich mit
verboten
und davor schrecken SPD und FDP mehr
zurück weil sie länger denken und sagen
wir wollen aber auch wieder gewählt
werden und die Haltung bei Herrn Lindner
dem Finanzminister und dem Bundeskanzler
die ist
jedenfalls stärker als bei den Grünen
wir müssen die Menschen mitnehmen einige
sind überfordert wenn wir beim
Heizungstausch daran denken dass es eben
nicht damit getan ist für 18.000 Euro
eine Wärmepumpe einzubauen sondern dass
man das Haus sanieren muss was sehr
schnell bei 70.000 Euro landet und wenn
Menschen mit 60 gerade ihr Haus
abgezahlt haben wahrscheinlich gar
keinen Kredit mehr in der Höhe kriegen
ähnlich bei den Autos viele fahren ein
alter ein altes Auto und SPD und FDP
haben für sich beschlossen wir können
nicht alles abschaffen wir können die
Leute nicht weiter verunsichern die
wählen uns nie wieder und die Grünen
sind noch mit mehr ähm
Konsequenz da drin Räumen aber eher sehr
wohl ihren ähm ihr ihr Misserfolg da
auch ein und das was jetzt passiert ist
in dieser Koalition
dass sie dadurch wirklich fragil wird
dass sie sich beim Klimawandel was ja
sagen wir mal nach der Überwindung der
Pandemie und mit dem Versuch den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine zu
überwinden die ganz große
Zukunftsaufgabe das größte Problem ist
und bleibt darüber werden Sie sich
weiter sehr sehr zerstreiten und auch
auch die stabilisieren ja ich würde
sozusagen dann in der Formulierung
widersprechen ich habe gerade das Gefühl
dass SPD und FDP nicht weiter in die
Zukunft schauen sondern sie schauen nur
bis zur nächsten Wahl und ich finde es
ist eine Aussage
ich finde die haben einen sehr
kurzfristigen Blick während
die Zukunft blicken müssen und ich
glaube wir haben gerade eine Situation
wo sehr sehr viele Menschen die meisten
Menschen in diesem Land verstanden haben
was für ein großes Problem die
Klimakrise und wo sie sich auch selber
sorgen machen also wie was wird selber
passieren mit der nächsten Hitzewelle
was wird wie wird das meinen Kindern in
der Zukunft gehen die ist unerträglich
finden die Bilder von Naturkatastrophen
aus der ganzen Welt zu sehen und die
gleichzeitig natürlich bei den aktuellen
Debatten auch eine persönliche
Verunsicherung spüren und ich glaube das
ist das kann ich nachvollziehen und das
muss man auch adressieren und ich glaube
dass es aber an der Stelle einen ganz
ganz großes Problem ist dass man
politisch so tut als würde ist den
Menschen in diesem Land gut gehen wenn
man diese Veränderung nicht jetzt
geplant umsetzt ich verstehe den den
Ansatz von und auch die Frustration und
bei ihnen verstehe ich total
andererseits tut sich da gerade eine
gigantische neue soziale Frage auf genau
der Punkt das ist genau der Punkt sie
haben auch dazu glaube ich getwittert
vielleicht können wir das einmal ganz
kurz einspielen folgen Sie mir auf
Twitter oder ist verfolgen nur im Grunde
und speziell auch Nacht
sagen ja wenn ich nicht schlafen kann
dann lese ich Tweets von Martin Huber
also sozial ungerecht und eine nicht zu
verantworten Überlastung insbesondere
für ältere Hausbesitzer ne das darf
nicht zu Altersarmut führen und so
weiter bei grüner sanierungszwang und so
davor haben sie einen Punkt aber wie
würden sie es machen
es geht darum dass wir natürlich mit
Förderprogrammen die Menschen begleiten
aber nicht übers Knie brechen wenn ich
jetzt lese bei der Ampel das im nächsten
Jahr die Heizungen ausgewechselt werden
müssen das teilweise sogar in Anspruch
genommen wird in Privathaushalten mit
Wasserstoff zu halten
Alternativen Fakten also wirklich wenn
wenn eine Heizung kaputt geht so ja so
und dann musste sie war der Plan
völlig andere Aussage
nächstes Jahr müssen alle Heizungen
ausgewechselt werden bitte dann das ist
einfach dann machen
mit
wasserstoffeinheiten warum machen das
müssen sie natürlich erstmal überlegen
wo soll denn der Wasserstoff herkommen
kommen verstehen
dass demnächst alle Heizungen in
Deutschland ausgetauscht werden müssen
was völliger
es war schon am Beginn auch die
Überlegung dass man einen
sanierungszwang kombiniert natürlich
auch mit den Vorgaben der europame
ein Kompromiss der lautet
80-Jährige das Thema das wissen sie so
viel besser als ich weiß
trotzdem ist doch der Punkt wenn ich
trotzdem warum trotzdem ist doch der
Punkt dass wir das verstehen
warum warum setzt man sich nicht hin und
sagt was auf hier ist unser
konstruktiver guter Vorschlag ich
versteh total
dass wir eine abfragtprämie einführen
für alte Heizungen und die Menschen zu
begleiten bei der Umstellung ohne dass
wir sie zwingen weil es natürlich schon
auch um die Frage geht wie sie gerade in
meinem Tweet auch eingeblendet haben
freut mich ja und es geht natürlich
schon auch darum dass Menschen wie sie
Frau gesagt hat die über 30 40 Jahre
Eigenheim vom Mund
abgespeicherprämie werden sie machen
heißt
darüber reden kann 80% zu bezuschussen
damit die Menschen bei der Umstellung
unterstützt und begleitet werden ohne
dass sie sich Prozent ohne dass wir
jetzt in den Bestand oder ein Eigentum
eingreifen oder irgendwas brechen weil
sie haben selber angesprochen es geht ja
auch um eine soziale Frage absolut es
ist richtig
darüber hinaus auch noch einen Punkt
wenn wir uns ja auch einig sind das
Klimaschutz ein globales Anliegen ist da
muss ich natürlich schon immer auch
schauen dass bei uns die
Rahmenbedingungen sind dass das nicht so
Abwanderungen führen und deswegen sind
neues Thema deswegen sind auch so
wichtig weil wir können bei uns
natürlich alles umstellen auf
Immobilität aber
vor dem Hintergrund einer globalen
Herausforderung muss ich mir noch
überlegen
wie wird denn dann in anderen Teilen der
Welt Mobilität organisiert und da ist
doch dann könnte man jetzt lange darüber
reden was Volkswagen auch gibt und
politisch war aber ganz kurz Kristina
hat uns das interessant ne also ist das
eine der Gründe also was ich sehr
schwierig finde ist Herr Huber wenn Sie
ganz gezielt und ganz bewusst Dinge
falsch wiedergeben um Stimmung zu machen
wir haben eine sehr aufgeheizte
Diskussion im Land und wir haben eine
große Verunsicherung weil die Menschen
natürlich jetzt Angst bekommen
Veranstaltung wenn sie sie könnten viel
dazu beitragen als CSU als große
Volkspartei wenn sie mit aufklären
würden und wenn sie nicht Dinge die
abgeräumt sind wieder hervorholen und
die Leute weiter verunsichern und es
Frau Brüder hat am Anfang gesagt
Landtagswahlkampf in Bayern ist das
allerwichtigste für die CSU auf der Welt
was höheres gibt es nicht okay ja
das ist okay für eine Partei wichtig
wenn Wahnsinn ist finde ich geht ist zu
weit wenn man eben nicht von Heimat
Energie und einem Bundesland
die in die in die ganze Republik so
ausstrahlen darf dass alle darunter
leiden müssen weil in Bayern
Landtagswahlkampf ist das finde ich geht
zu weit und wenn sie
sozialen Frage Herr Huber sie schlagen
eine Abwrackprämie vor das aber auch nur
ganz kleiner Teil wenn Sie sich jetzt in
die Lage versetzen würden wie so eine
Ampel oder wie eine Bundesregierung was
sie danach denken muss es geht ja nicht
nur um eine
abfahrtprämie sondern sie müssen dann
der der Spruch der ampelregierung ist
niemand wird im Stich gelassen den kann
ich auch nicht mehr hören ehrlich gesagt
weil das natürlich überhaupt nicht
besagt wo da der Schnitt gemacht wird
worum es mir geht ist und dazu ist die
CSU unglaublich wichtig wir müssen über
einen neuen wohlstandsbegriff sprechen
Frau Brünger hat die Generation von Frau
Brünger hat ein ganz anderen
wohlstandsbegriff als wir und ich finde
da können wir sehr viel von dem
Engagement lernen zu Wohlstand gehört
ich habe Wasser ich habe saure Bares
Wasser ich habe Strom ich habe es warm
ich muss nicht frieren und dafür muss
ich andere Dinge die bisher mein
wohlstandsbegriff geprägt haben bereit
sein abzugeben zum Beispiel zum Beispiel
ja zum Beispiel dass ich mir gehen wir
mal zum Auto dass ich nicht darauf
bestehen kann das Auto was nachweislich
die Umwelt verpestet bis 2:35 Uhr noch
wir könnten viel oder wir müssten viel
radikaler sein meiner Ansicht nach
brauchen wir ein Tempolimit lange
verpennt von der CSU im
Verkehrsministerium jetzt von der FDP im
Verkehrsminister wir müssten an an
vielen auch kleinen Stellen sagen das
ist uns nicht mehr so wichtig weil mir
gutes Essen wichtig ist nicht aus
massentier Haltung weil es auch den
Klimawandel befördert und die CSU mit
ihrem wie ich finde ja beeindruckenden
guten Heimatbegriff könnte das besonders
gut machen was sie aber machen ist um
die Landtagswahl zu gewinnen gegen diese
Ampel die ja sehr im Sinne von Herrn
Söder war er wollte ja damals gar nicht
groß in die Regierung einsteigen und hat
das ja mit verhindert eine
Jamaika-Koalition und genau sind wir
wieder beim bayerischen
Landtagswahlkampf um genau das zu machen
was sie jetzt machen mit dem Schießen
gegen Berlin ist ja ohnehin ein gutes
Feindbild für die CSU in Bayern daraus
wollen sie gewinnen schlagen und das
wird Ihnen zu einem Teil wahrscheinlich
auch gelingen nur das bringt dem Land
nichts und das finde ich ist für eine
Volkspartei der Größe der CSU überhaupt
nicht würdig